the greatest gift to the libertarian
electorate was the Obama administration
my name is Jack Pitney I'm a professor
of government at Claremont McKenna
College we're here at Claremont McKenna
College in the Marian minor cook happen
am is there a libertarian electorate in
the United States well that's hard to
say the most consistent aspect of public
opinion in the United States is
inconsistency the great virtue of the
libertarian philosophy is consistency
limited government in both the economic
realm things such as government spending
and regulation as well as the social
realm here we're talking about issues
such as abortion and Drug Control this
is an appealing philosophy for some
Americans but public opinion is more
complicated than that in part because
people don't follow politics very
closely so on certain issues you can
definitely see libertarian tendencies
there's a libertarian strain in American
political thought but the hardcore
libertarian electorate is actually
fairly small libertarians are treated as
if they have quirky believes precisely
because they're consistent in the
country where a lot of people have
inconsistent beliefs and adherence to
principal a consistent adherence to
principal sometimes looks pretty unusual
to the extent that you do have a
libertarian electorate tends to be
younger people tends to be people who
are have a background in economics and
who because of their life experiences
believe in a hands-off policy on social
life
a a lot of people are grabbing for the
libertarian label because it sounds very
appealing libertarian sounds a lot like
liberty and Americans like Liberty so
it's a it's a good handle to have and
it's one that a lot of people reach for
even though it doesn't always fit
because a lot of the people who say they
favor smaller government in the abstract
tend to favor larger government in the
particular you don't get that many true
libertarians in big business because big
business likes regulations that
disadvantage their competitors they like
doing a lot of business with the
government if you go to town hall
meetings during the day a
disproportionate share of the people at
those town hall meetings have white hair
even though they may call themselves
limited government people they're
passionate supporters of Social Security
people who grew up in the greatest
generation tended to be very favorable
toward the New Deal many of them served
in the Second World War they were used
to big organizations big units in
American society younger people today
are definitely more libertarian than
people who grew up in the greatest
generation for this reason the greatest
gift to the libertarian electorate was
the Obama administration the problem
that libertarians have had is making the
case against big government at times
when government hasn't been growing as
big at a time when you have massive
expansion of government power massive
government spending people start to see
the downsides of that philosophy and the
libertarian philosophy starts to become
more appealing but you have to put it in
perspective the vast majority of voters
aren't going to read the Road to Serfdom
or the constitution of Liberty
nevertheless starting from a relatively
small base the libertarian electorate
has a good deal of room for growth and
precisely because of the Obama
administration we're seeing increased
attention to libertarian ideas
obviously the office holder who most
closely represents the libertarian
electorate is Ron Paul ron paul formerly
the Libertarian Party candidate for
president most issues straight down the
line libertarian limited government in
the economic and social realm although
Ron Paul is pro-life on abortion Ron
Paul excited so many young people in the
last election cycle because he stood for
something he told the truth as he saw it
he was somebody who didn't seem to be
repeating the same talking points and
applause lines as other politicians and
that was very appealing to many young
Americans I think it would be very
difficult for a president to be elected
on a strictly libertarian platform for
example take the issue of Social
Security libertarians believe in
privatization of Social Security that is
a very difficult sell for many Americans
particularly senior citizens President
Bush learned that in 2005 when he
attempted even a partial privatization
of Social Security the move wasn't very
popular nevertheless I think it is very
possible for Americans to elect a
president who has a basic commitment to
limited government though as a pragmatic
matter there may be some departures from
that basic principle that's the way
political life works libertarians can be
swing voters in certain circumstances in
some Republican primaries you definitely
get a libertarian segment coming out to
vote in the general electorate the swing
voters tend to be independence and it's
hard to describe any kind of consistent
ideology to which they adhere again the
most consistent aspect of American
public opinion is inconsistency
well the internet does have serious
implications for the libertarian
movement it's a way to communicate it's
a way to educate and it's an equalizer
by which I mean this conservatives and
liberals control the the major
organizations of American culture and
American Society the libertarian
movement is more decentralized and the
internet is a great tool for a far-flung
constituency to find itself and to
communicate with one another